y reparar una relación dañada el
presidente francés emmanuel macrón y el
primer ministro australiano anthony
albanese se reunieron en parís para
buscar un nuevo comienzo en los lazos
bilaterales luego de que australia
anulará en septiembre de 2021 un
contrato de 62 mil millones de dólares
para que una empresa francesa
construyera una flota de 12 submarinos
tras la cancelación por parte de
australia del contrato el presidente de
francia de manuel macro le calificó de
mentiroso al primer ministro australiano
scott marsans y pidió el retiro de su
embajador del país oceánico sin embargo
hoy buscan reparar los lazos rotos
estoy muy contento señor primer ministro
de recibirlo hoy en parís y este viaje
después de nuestro intercambio
telefónico de hace unas semanas justo
después de su elección lo que marca una
relación de confianza entre nuestros dos
países una relación basada en el respeto
mutuo después como bien sabemos de una
fase difícil difícil
una nueva negociación entre parís y
canberra que será mucho mayor que el
acuerdo cancelado el año pasado con una
inversión de 583 millones de dólares con
el grupo naval de francia
mi presencia aquí tras la invitación del
presidente macro no representa un nuevo
comienzo para la relación de nuestros
países francia es un socio antiguo y
valioso para australia y aprecio la
cálida bienvenida que he recibido aquí
la relación de australia con francia
importa la confianza el respeto y la
honestidad son importantes spect en este
mes
el nuevo primer ministro laborista que
derrotó a morrison en las elecciones de
mayo ha dado prioridad a la restauración
de la imagen internacional de australia
específicamente en la lucha contra el
cambio climático